so i had a question from someone that
wanted to know what am i going to do
with this constant urge to
urinate okay it's all the time not just
at night
so there's three main causes number one
a uti which is a urinary tract infection
number two
you have blood sugar issues high levels
of sugar
now it could also be a pre-diabetic
situation
or even insulin resistance we'll get to
that in a bit
or a kidney stone so if you have a
kidney stone that can also cause this
so if you're male it could be that your
prostate is enlarged
if you're female it could be because
you have a fibroid and of course you can
just have an infection
or it could be just a kind of a
precursor to even pre-diabetes
now if you happen to have to pee but you
feel that your bladder
isn't fully emptied and you want to be
able to
figure out if that's the case all you
have to do is after you go to the
bathroom
press just above the pubis bone
okay which is down in the front part of
the pelvis and you press in there
and if you have the urge to pee that
means that your bladder is not empty
and that could mean if you're a guy the
prostate
is slightly enlarged in which case you
need to avoid
dairy products you need to avoid soy
products
and of course you need to do keto and
intermittent fasting too
and you will probably see huge changes
with that and there's two other
remedies that i would recommend in this
situation number one
pumpkin seeds you can do that as a
supplement
or you can start eating pumpkin seeds
right after your meal there's a certain
phytonutrient in pumpkin seeds
that not only helps the prostate but it
can also increase the flow of urine
the other thing you want to do as well
is consume large salads because
that is going to increase the potassium
and also the amount of fluid that goes
through your body so you're not
retaining fluid
if you're consuming foods high in
potassium it can act as a diuretic
and the last thing i would recommend for
men would be something called saw
palmetto
which can decrease the very powerful
form of testosterone called dht so
that would be the recommendation for
that now this recommendation is for
men and women and it's very important in
fact it's the most important thing
you should do whether you're urinating
at night
and by the way it's not normal to
urinate at all through the night
as well as having frequent urination
through the day okay
the number one thing to do is go on a
low carb diet
and really do it for real cut your carbs
way down i put a link down below of what
to do
think about this fluid water
follows sugar and carbs
so if you're doing more sugar and more
carbs you're gonna have more
water going through the kidney and
you're going to have excessive amount of
urination
so you want to do the healthy version of
the ketogenic diet with
intermittent fasting i put the link down
below
next thing is if you have a uti
not only will the ketogenic diet help
that but there's a couple
great remedies one would be d mannose
take 1500 milligrams a day and you can
split it up to the day or
one time it doesn't really matter the
other tea that seems to work really good
is called
coqui tea and you can drink that to the
day not right before bed though
and pumpkin seeds which will increase
the flow of urine and help you
empty the bladder not to mention large
amounts of salad
and vegetables to increase your
potassium so you're not retaining any
fluid
all right go ahead and apply this and
put your comments down below
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today